This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to the Tim Ferriss show.
What you are about to hear is part two of a two part conversation with Alex
Bloomberg,
best known for his work with this American life as cohost of planet money and
also co founder of gimlet media which has produced to blockbuster podcasts at
the time of this particular episode,
namely Startup and reply all.
He is a true master of storytelling,
crafting,
narrative,
radio,
interviewing and much more.
If you didn't catch the first part,
you might want to do that before venturing in,
but you can certainly listen to this independently.
This second part is an excerpt from a masterclass that he taught on creative
live.com I think costs about $99 and it is phenomenal.
Specifically in this portion we are going to look at the art of the interview
and how to craft and find the perfect question so I hope you enjoy it and
without further ado,
please enjoy part two of the Tim Ferriss show with Alex Bloomberg.
Optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Question.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue over.
What we're going to be talking about,
uh,
in this segment is the art of the interview.
Um,
and what I'm going to be covering today,
uh,
what I'm going to be covering this in this section is first of all,
like sort of the most basic question,
which is what,
what are you going for when you're interviewing somebody?
What are you trying to get out of it?
What is the thing that you want to,
what does a,
what does a good interview look like?
Right?
What does it feel like when it's happening?
Um,
uh,
and as part of that,
I'm going to go through what to ask.
How do you come up with the questions,
uh,
to ask?
Um,
and uh,
and I mean maybe talking a little bit about the power of the right question.
Um,
uh,
and then I'm also going to be talking about nuts and bolts.
So that's coming up.
Um,
so,
uh,
what are you going for?
Um,
so the first thing that you're,
that you're going for a,
is what we,
what we talked about in the last section,
which is a fintech moments of,
you know,
sort of authentic moments of authentic emotion,
authentic sort of realization,
authentic moments of humor is something that feels like a real emotion.
Like those,
those are golden moments in an interview.
And that's sort of,
that's one of the things that you're absolutely want to go for.
And we talked a little bit about that before and I'm going to talk about that a
little bit later.
Um,
but the thing that I want to focus on now is the other thing that we're talking
about is,
um,
stories and this and that.
And I am,
I have a,
um,
have had sort of a,
a very specific meaning when I,
when I say what an actual story is.
Um,
but I'm going to,
um,
but I think the first thing to do is to,
is to,
sorry,
sorry.
Uh,
I think the first thing to do is,
uh,
to play you a little bit of what I'm talking about when I'm talking about a
story.
So I'm going to play you a little piece of tape.
So this is story that was on this American life a while ago.
And um,
the setup is that is this actor Tate Donovan Donovan is,
it was a sort of a character actor.
He'd been,
you know,
sort of on a couple of different shows,
but you can get recognized very much.
And then he had like a stint on friends and all of a sudden you're starting to
get recognized.
And it was really exciting for him to be recognized because he finally got to be
the celebrity that he always wished that he could be at the celebrity that he
would have wanted to meet before he was famous.
Uh,
so when he got recognized and so one and this story happens when one night he
was out at this Broadway show and a lot of people were coming up to him and be
like,
Hey,
I saw you.
And he was able to like talk to people and be very magnanimous and say thank you
so much.
It really means a lot.
And he was like posing for pictures for people.
And it was at the show.
It was happening over and over and over again.
I was,
I was exactly how I want it to be.
I was doing it,
I was doing great.
And then
the kid with the camera came along,
this nervous kid,
he must have been 16 years old,
he's in a rented Tuxedo,
unbelievably like shy and awkward and he's got like an acne and he's got a
camera in his hand and underneath the marquee is his date,
who is literally like a Po,
a prom dress,
and she's got a corsage and she's really,
you know,
nervous and sort of clutching your hands.
And he sort of comes up to me and he sort of mumbles something like,
you know something about a picture.
And I'm like,
I just feel for him.
So I'm like,
oh,
absolutely.
My Gosh,
sure,
no problem.
My God,
you poor thing.
And,
and I go up to,
is it his girlfriend?
I wrap my arms around her and I'm like,
Hey,
where are your from?
Fantastic.
Going to see the play.
It's great.
And the guys sort of not taking the photograph very quickly.
He's just sort of staring at me and he's got his camera,
his hands and standby is like chin,
you know,
and,
and uh,
she's very stiff and awkward and I don't know what to do.
So I just leaned across and I kissed her on the cheek and I'm like,
all right,
God,
take the fixture,
hurry up.
Do you guys want to find out what happens next?
That's a story.
Uh,
when you want to,
so what that is the power of a good narrative.
So when I talk about,
I'm talking about like those two basic things,
you're going for emotion and narrative.
We as humans are hardwired,
I believe,
to listen to narrative and,
and it's a very simple sort of the mechanics of narrative or very simple.
There's like a sequence of actions and those sort of rising action and it's
culminating in something.
Um,
and you were in the middle of that sequence of actions and you were about to get
to the culmination and I stopped it and it's frustrating and you really want to
know what happens next.
And you would never,
if you were listening to this,
have turned off that podcast or that radio story at that moment.
And that is a good story.
And that's why you want to operate in stories.
That's why you,
when you're interviewing people,
you want to get their stories out of them.
Um,
and you want to get them talking in stories because stories are what we want to
hear.
Um,
and so when you're working in an audio format,
you need to operate in stories.
Um,
the other thing we want to hear as we heard before it is emotion.
So those are the two things you're going for it and a good interview.
Um,
so moving on,
actually,
do you want to hear what happens next?
All right.
Um,
I'll rewind it again and then we'll get,
well,
we'll have it play out.
I don't know what to do.
So I just lean across and I kissed her on the cheek and I'm like,
all right,
go ahead and take the mixture of hurry up.
And,
and finally he sort of like snaps it and uh,
I'm like,
okay,
it was really wonderful to meet you.
And he just like stammered over to me and was like,
mmm,
could you take a picture of us?
Okay.
Oh,
and the whole time he just wanted me to take a picture of him and his girlfriend
underneath the awning of the play.
He didn't want a picture of me.
I had no idea who I was.
Oh God.
Got a little emotion in there too.
Yeah.
Um,
so that is what I'm talking about when it's the right.
So did like very,
very simply,
we're going to be talking a lot more about what story is in the next session,
but,
but very,
very simply,
it is that it is a sequence of actions that culminates in something come,
some sort of revelation,
some sort of punchline,
some sort of jokes.
I'm sort of like realization.
Um,
and more to the point,
it's something that you don't want to turn off that you don't want to stop
listening to.
Um,
and so when,
so that is the thing that's in your mind when you're going out and doing an
interview with anybody.
You want to ask questions of the interview subject that are going to either
elicit an honest emotional reaction or they're going to elicit them telling you
a story.
Um,
so,
and there's a lot of things that you can ask,
um,
that,
that well,
so let's,
let's talk about that.
So,
um,
so what the ask,
right?
So first if you're trying to ask questions that will elicit his story.
Um,
first of all,
you don't want to ask ever really yes or no questions.
I mean,
you've got to get some facts out of the way,
but you don't want to ask a yes or no question because that is not,
that's the end of a story,
right?
Um,
and,
uh,
so you,
how you phrase the questions is very,
very important.
Um,
you want to sort of ask questions.
I often sort of say,
tell me about the time when you write something,
you know,
you were just like,
you want to tell you,
you can use where it's like,
tell me.
Um,
so there are automatically starting to talk to you in,
in story language.
Um,
tell me about the time.
Tell me about the day when you blah,
blah,
blah.
Tell me about the moment when you realized that this was what was going to
happen.
Tell me about the,
the,
the time in your life when you were going through this thing.
Um,
uh,
another question that works really well.
Tell me the story of just ask them straight up,
right.
You know,
none of this story of this,
how did this happen?
Tell me the story.
You know,
sometimes that works.
Um,
uh,
another thing that you,
when you use that you,
when you're on the right track,
you know,
when you're on the right track is when people are actually sort of like talking
to you in dialog.
If somebody is saying,
well,
first I said,
and then she said,
and then I said,
ah,
that's really that.
You know,
you're on the right track here.
So often I will tell people,
you know,
describe the conversation where Blah Blah Blah.
And cause if you get people sort of telling you like he said,
then she said,
then he said that she said,
that's great.
You know,
you're on the right track but somebody is telling you a story right then,
um,
cause they're quoting dialogue to,
again,
tell me about the,
the,
often what you're going for is a moment of realization.
So a story has to culminate in something often.
It's often the thing that's culminating in is a moment of realization.
Uh,
so you want to say,
tell me about the day that you realize whatever it is that we're talking about
here.
Um,
another thing that really works well,
um,
is if people can sort of talk through a process of,
you know,
there's,
there's often steps that led from one situation to the other situation.
What were the steps that got you from one thing to another?
What were the steps that got you from,
you know,
your career in the offer army to,
to your career as a,
as a,
as a celebrity florist or whatever.
Right?
So,
uh,
anybody here have that career trajectory by the way?
Uh,
um,
so,
uh,
so you want to ask that like sort of what were the steps,
if you can get people breaking that down into steps and often each step is its
own story.
So often step one will be,
well,
I was at,
you know,
I was,
I was at,
I was no,
I had my career in the army and this one thing happened when I was in the army
that this day happened that I wanted,
that made me want to change.
And so they'll tell you that.
And that's a story.
Each step can be its own story,
but the,
the,
that,
that sequence of steps is also a story.
Um,
so these are all sort of questions that will,
that will elicit stories.
You want to have people back up,
you want to do all that stuff.
All right,
so that's one whole set of questions.
Um,
and often when you're doing,
uh,
so that's a whole set of questions.
The other set of questions.
So what do you ask if there's a whole other set of questions that are built
around eliciting sort of honest reflection and emotion.
So that's the other stock and trade.
That's the other thing that you're going for,
right?
Pretty simple.
Two things.
Um,
so what do you,
so what do you ask or when you're trying to get people to tell you,
um,
you don't tell you how they feel.
One question is,
how'd that make you feel?
It's pretty straight forward.
Uh,
there's a,
um,
I often joke that like doing a good interview for audio and,
and,
and having a good sort of therapy session look very similar.
Um,
because what you are trying to do is get people to articulate their emotions in
words.
All you have an audio,
our words,
that's all you have.
You have people's words.
And so if they're feeling something,
it's like if something happens and you're not shooting at it didn't happen.
If they're feeling something and they don't articulate it,
it also didn't happen.
So you need them to articulate the way they're feeling.
And so a lot of what you're doing is you're in the audience,
you're in the interview,
and you're like,
I noticed feeling and your voice or in your manner,
and I want you to articulate that feeling.
Um,
and so,
um,
so that's one thing.
And so that's like how did that make you feel?
Is A,
is a,
is a big,
is a big one.
Often you also want to encourage that kind of reflection.
Some people just aren't very naturally reflective,
but they've gone through something sort of momentous and you want them sort of
like getting that,
getting the,
the,
the emotion in there.
So one good trick I,
I've,
I've known is sort of like,
if the old new could see the new you,
what would the old you say?
Um,
because often you're going,
you're,
you know,
you're interviewing about something that has happened to them.
They've gone through some sort of transition and you want the,
you want that
moment.
You,
you want them to be able to articulate what that transition meant to them.
Um,
and these are all tricks.
We're going to use by the way,
on one of our audience members and coming up.
Uh,
so we're going to do a live interview coming up in another section.
So,
uh,
so these are all sort of take notes cause we're going to have to employ this and
you know,
use this an action.
Um,
so,
um,
uh,
a lot of what emotion is around is around internal conflict.
Um,
so a lot of,
uh,
and this is one of the things that I love about audio,
which audio can do uniquely well,
is that it can give voice to interior sort of interior drama.
Uh,
if there's,
you know,
on television you can sort of see people looking pensively or you can sort of
like,
you can sort of,
you can get across an eternal life,
but stuff has to happen on,
you know,
on tape,
it has to be happening.
And with audio that you can,
if you can give people,
if you can get people to give voice to these,
to the internal conflict,
it has the power of any kind of real drama.
So,
so what I often say to people is like I'll often say like so complex you're
going for conflict,
but it can be conflict within a person.
It can be a person feeling conflicted about something.
And so a big question that I use a lot,
which is sort of like just if you had to describe the debate in your head over
this moment over this act that you took,
what was one side saying?
What was the other side?
And saying,
you know,
um,
and it's just getting people to sort of like voice this,
this the feelings that they're having and often our feelings or contradictory.
Right?
And so you want that and that's great if people have a conflicted feeling when
you're interviewing them,
that's a wonderful thing too.
That's what you want.
Cause that's the way of breaking out of what you were talking about an which is
the canned thing.
Part of what being canned is,
is just sort of just having like a,
you know,
sort of like a very,
very straightforward feeling about it that you don't necessarily believe but you
can't shake people out of.
And so what you want is to sort of like get at like,
you know,
what,
what was the conflict?
Was there ever a point where you didn't feel so confident competent about this?
Was there ever a point where you like,
felt different?
Like,
you know,
sort of like,
and sort of,
and sometimes it can be just as simple as sort of like,
you seem very confident right now.
Was that always the case?
You know?
And if they say no,
then just zero in on that like zero head on the weakness,
uh,
the emotion,
right?
Like that's what you're,
that's what your job is.
Right.
Um,
and then another question that I would
often happens in an interview on a batch of this,
this will happen to you as you're doing your interviews.
Somebody will say something and it feels like very important to them.
Like they've said something but you know,
is meaningful.
Uh,
you know,
like,
you're talking to like a,
you know,
a rail yard worker and there'll be like,
well,
you know,
and then the,
the,
the boss gave us like,
you know,
extra hours and they say it like,
and you're like,
wow,
the boss gave you an extra hour and you're seeing it.
Like it's important that I have no idea what it means,
but it means something to you there.
Emotion in the voice,
right?
Like what does that mean?
And so,
and often you and I would always love this thing.
I would know that there was something that they were getting at,
but they weren't articulating it to me.
And,
and then,
and then IRA used this question,
use this question all the time.
And it's a really great question and it's super straight forward.
It's just sort of like,
what do you make of that?
And so I say it all the time now because like I'm often,
I just need them to tell me the reason that there's emotion in the thing that
they just said.
Um,
so what do you make of that?
Is it,
it's a really,
uh,
really,
a really important question.
Um,
the other thing that I think one of the most important things that we,
yeah,
which is sort of like part of the whatever you make,
what do you make of that question again?
Uh,
you sort of ask what he make of that and then you're
okay.
It's sort of a dumb question.
Uh,
you sort of feel like an idiot for asking and it's like sort of like basic and
weird and like it's not a question that you actually asked that often in normal
conversation.
Uh,
and so,
and this gets to the point of sort of like,
are you having a real conversation?
Are you having a staged conversation sort of to elicit certain things and you're
doing a little bit of both,
right?
And then what did you make of that is very much like a staged sort of therapy
kind of conversation.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
and so,
but really important is to then shut up.
I can't get across enough the importance of shutting up.
And like early on in my career I would come back and I would just be talking so
much and people would start to be telling me interesting things and I would be
talking over them and,
and it was all because I was nervous and I was worried about like sort of making
them feel uncomfortable and you sort of want them to feel uncomfortable a little
bit,
not totally uncomfortable so that they're not going to be like talking to you.
You want them to feel,
you want them to feel safe,
but you want them to feel like they're saying something real,
which is often uncomfortable.
So you want it to be safe.
You're not judgmental at all,
you never want to be judgemental,
but you want to be asking real questions and you want them to be thinking real
really about them.
So,
um,
another,
another just sort of,
you know,
good,
good question that sort of gets at this is the,
is the why is the story meaningful to you
coming up?
The power of the right question and how to craft it to get honest responses,
deep responses including plenty of clips.
But first a short word from our sponsors.
The Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim that's [inaudible] it.com forward
slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything.
Graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review.
You are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times for banner ads.
And you can check out some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com.
Forward Slash Tim,
you can also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim
and now back to the show.
So just to sort of get across like sort of like the power of like sort of what
this,
what this question is asking the right question.
Um,
I wanna I wanna play a,
a couple clips of,
of tape here.
Um,
and this first one is like,
um,
a story that we did on.
So this,
this first sort of like illustration of the power of asking the right question
and getting people to reflect honestly.
Um,
it's a weird story.
Uh,
it was a sort of this really conceptual story that we did at this American life
a while ago and it was this reporter named Davy Rothbart.
And I was the producer on this story.
So I went out with him and asked all these questions.
And the conceptual story was this,
Debbie lived on this block in Chicago that was sort of like a sort of a black
and transition.
There was like some sort of yuppies moving in,
but it had been sort of like a poor,
there's some gang problems there.
And it was like a sort of a neat,
it was a neighborhood in transition.
Um,
and he lived on this block and there was all these problems that with the
neighborhood was having with each other,
like different neighbors were like having different conflicts with each other.
And there was like a neighbor in this building who was complaining about his
loud music and was constantly banging on the floor.
And then there was another neighbor that had thought that like that somebody
else stole her dog.
And then there was like,
you know,
so there's all these things and,
and the idea was that Davey was the idea of the story.
It was a Davy was gonna sort of like collect all these prompts,
interview all the people in his neighborhood,
and then take the problems that were happening in this neighborhood to an expert
on neighbor relations.
Call it five 44 round trips.
I set up the wrong piece of tape.
I mean,
sorry.
A trap that,
oh,
there it is right there in my notes.
I missed it.
Um,
I'm going to set up a different use.
Dave,
there's another piece here.
This is what would it be very quickly,
sorry.
Keep all that in your mind for a second.
Um,
and uh,
there's two,
there's two stories I'm gonna play.
I'm going play the first one now in order.
Um,
so,
uh,
so this is a different story.
This was one that I did on the housing crisis.
This is a story from 2008.
And it was one of the more famous famous stories I did was called the giant pool
of money.
And it was about the housing meltdown basically.
Um,
and,
uh,
back in 2008,
there was all this stuff happening with subprime mortgages and a lot of the
coverage was about our,
um,
who,
you know,
like who's at fault,
is it like we're dead beats taking out loans that they knew they couldn't pay
back and then like ripping off the banks or were like poor people being
victimized by evil banks that were now foreclosing on their homes.
And that was the sort of the narrative and neither narrative really ever made
sense to me.
And I kept on thinking like,
there's like there's something else going on here,
something bigger and more systemic that's going on then just like either people
ripping off banks or banks where if you have people,
um,
and I wanted to get at the heart of it and there was like this question.
So,
so we found this guy who was,
who was going through foreclosure and he was telling the story of how,
of how he got this loan,
this enormous loan.
And in the middle of this clip,
you'll hear the question that I'm talking about,
the question that I felt like turned the whole thing and sort of set up the
entire show as a matter of fact,
but sort of got him talking in a very different way.
Um,
so this guy's name is Clarence.
He'd taken out a huge loan,
almost over half a million dollars at the time of that loan,
had three not very reliable part time jobs.
He was making about $45,000 a year.
Um,
and on the loan that he took out,
they didn't ask him anything about his income.
Call it five 40 for round figures.
Do you basically borrowed $540,000 from the bank and they didn't check your
income.
All right.
They'd say no income verification loan.
They don't call me up and say,
you know how much money they don't do that.
I mean,
it's,
it's almost like you pass a guy in the street and you say,
Hey,
let me $540,000.
He said,
well,
what do you do?
Heck,
I job.
Okay.
Hit named it.
It,
it's,
it's seems as if it's that casual,
even though there were a lot of papers that get filled out and stuff flies all
over with the faxes and the emails and all like that.
Essentially
that's the process.
Would you have loaned you the money?
I wouldn't have loaned me the money and um,
nobody that I know would have loaned me the money.
I mean,
I know guys who are criminals that wouldn't lend me that money and they break
your kneecap.
So yeah,
I mean
I'm serious.
I mean $540,000 a person with bad credit.
So I love that piece of tape because like it was the first time that the,
in my experience that anybody,
first of all,
clearance is at the center of the problem.
And I'm asking him how he feels about,
like that question got me,
enabled me to sidestep the whole,
whose fault is it in a way.
And it just got to a very honest reaction from him,
which was sort of like,
like the Wah.
There's all sorts of other ways to phrase that question.
Did you deserve that money?
Should the bank of giving you that money,
blah,
and all that would have led to a defensive answer.
It would have led to,
not the right answer,
but all this.
But then when I was like in the middle of it,
I remember thinking like,
oh,
that's the question.
And when I asked them,
wouldn't you have a loan you the money,
it forced him to be honest.
There was no way to sort of not be honest about answering that question.
Um,
and uh,
and it got like a really wonderful sort of honest response that then set up the
entire hour basically.
So like,
why were other people are lending money to people that those people themselves
would not have went to them.
Right?
So like what,
what was going on in there and that it's sort of like that,
that,
that question set up the entire thing.
All right,
so I teased this next piece of tape mistakenly.
So going back with cast your minds back to a,
when I set this up before,
uh,
so anyway,
Davy Rothbart taking,
getting all these questions from his,
uh,
from his,
um,
uh,
all these questions from his,
the people in his neighborhood and he's all the problems that he's running it by
an expert in neighbor relations.
Here's the bridge.
Mr. Rogers.
Yes,
Mr. Rogers,
who's since passed away,
uh,
Fred Rogers.
So I guess that it was a weird conceptual story.
We're taking these problems from this leg sort of like rough block of West
Augusta in Chicago and then bringing them in front of Mr. Rogers and asking him
to sort of pronounce judgment,
uh,
what these neighbors should do cause weird.
There's a backstory that I won't even get into.
Um,
but uh,
but it was,
I bring it up all to sort of talk about,
because there was,
this was one of these moments where like the question really brought us to a
different place.
One of the,
one of the things that they said there was this.
So one of the problems that Debbie had identified and we play one more piece of
tape and then we'll get to the,
the tape with the question.
So one of the problems that Davey had identified in his neighborhood was that
there was this fear,
right?
That was one of the big things.
So there was like people,
the people banging on the floor,
you know,
and the music playing too loud.
There was a kid,
there was a guy who was neighbor thought he'd stole her dog.
And then,
but mainly there was like a lot of fear.
There was like the fear of like the yuppies moving into,
into the neighborhood.
We're afraid of the kids who were in the gangs.
Um,
and uh,
and so David talked about that and you got your Davey and then you'll hear a kid
named the mouth who he's interviewing.
Okay.
Are you afraid of it?
Ask the only answer the same way.
The gangbangers,
the kids in baggy jeans and basketball jerseys.
Cruised the neighborhood with their stereos,
bumping the gang bangers.
They said those are the bad neighbors.
And maybe even 10,
you guess?
It's no surprise the mouth has his own idea about who the bad neighbors are.
The ones who fear and distrust him as a neighbor in the neighborhood that he
didn't agree with what we did so much.
So He'd,
he'd stand in his house with a video camera and record what we were doing.
Try to bring it to the beat meetings.
You know,
he used to follow us around with cameras,
literally follows around the neighborhood cameras,
you know,
and say,
I'm going to call the cops and using,
you know,
what,
for what we ain't bothering you.
You know,
that's what I think the worst neighbor is,
you know?
Yeah.
They come in here for us saying that,
you know,
maybe thinking that we're going to do this and do that,
but we'll talk to you.
You know what I'm saying,
Bro.
We ain't,
you know,
he ain't animals,
Bro.
We're normal people like you.
Cute.
All right.
So that's the mouth.
And his friends were sitting on the street drinking Heinekens and um,
so we bring that Mr. Rogers and so all that.
So Mr. Rogers is a wonderful,
lovely man.
Meeting him was like a thrill.
He's got this strange sort of power when you meet him.
It was crazy.
Uh,
he would like,
he,
when we went to meet him,
uh,
his assistant said we were trying to set up the interview and his assistant was
like,
well,
Fred likes to be nearby a piano.
Uh,
so we had to,
we had to meet him in his studio so that you can play the piano every once in
awhile.
He literally,
he had the bag of puppets and he would bring them out sometimes to make a point
and start talking in the puppet voices while we were talking to him.
And yet somehow it was like moving and real.
I don't know.
He was an amazing person.
Amazing.
Uh,
but he was getting,
he was us some,
a little bit of canned answers like when we were answering,
so what should this neighbor do?
His answer was always sorta sort of the same.
Like,
you know,
well,
I hope I would be brave enough to go and talk to them.
Okay.
I would hope that I would be brave enough to visit.
It's so easy.
She took condemn one.
We don't know.
And if I would visit you and find out that you are a reasonable person.
Okay.
I could tell you about my sensitivities and see if it would make any difference
to you.
Okay.
It's funny,
a lot of the things like,
you know,
you said if you were in Davies neighbors situation,
um,
you said that you hoped you would have enough courage to go down and visit and a
lot of what you were finding when you were talking to people had to do with that
same sort of notion.
And I'm wondering like what is it that we're afraid of?
Do you think?
Okay.
Perhaps we think that we won't find
another human being inside that person.
Okay.
Perhaps we think that all of their,
there may be,
are people in this world who I can't ever communicate with
and so I'll just give up before I try
and how sad it is to think that,
okay.
That we would give up
on any other creature who's just like us.
Okay.
So,
um,
what are your thoughts about that?
I taught,
I would love to hear what you'd like,
what,
what was going on in your mind?
Anybody respond?
Yeah.
And that was Mr. Rogers,
like that was so powerful.
And um,
he could hear that flutter in his voice,
which was his emotion,
you know,
rippling through his vocal chords.
And it was amazing.
And it was such an interesting contrast I think of Mr. Rogers and like,
it sounded like the Buddha,
wonderful Buddha legged person.
Yeah.
But it was like,
but that was one of the,
that was the,
that was the most honest moment in that,
in that interview,
you know,
and it,
and it came out of like,
there was this question that was sort of hovering over it and he was giving
slightly,
he sat and did I hear this?
And I wonder if you do too.
Like in the beginning he sounded more canned and then after I ask the question,
right,
you can hear it.
All of a sudden he's actually pausing and he's actually thinking and he's
actually trying to figure out what is the emotion and he's trying to voice that
emotion and all of a sudden it becomes a real and it becomes authentic and you
connect to that moment.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think the fact that he is Mr. Rogers carries particular weight.
Yeah.
We're used to hearing him and we're used to hearing him do those cans.
Simple solutions oriented,
just do this and it'll all be great for me that that moment of real darkness
when he identifies be greatest fear is I will never be able to communicate with
you.
Right?
Yeah.
And as a listener,
I can extrapolate that out to the neighborhood.
It's like I can see how that person would think bad about that person and it
just took me somewhere so hopeless when he was usually someone who's all about
positivity and it's going to be created.
So that juxtaposition of what I expect to hear from him and then what I hear
from him is incredibly powerful.
Right.
I think,
but I think that's a really great point because I think that's what you're
trying to do with it.
That's what,
that's what,
uh,
an honest moment.
We'll do it with anybody,
whether it's Mr. Rogers or not.
If you hear people talking and the way we all talk,
we're all sort of like,
you know,
going through or putting up fronts and lying to ourselves in various ways,
but as,
as we go through our day,
um,
and uh,
you know,
nobody's going to notice that I actually screwed up the order of my tape,
for example.
Uh,
but uh,
but you know that,
that,
that when they break,
when you break out of it,
even if you're not Mr. Rogers,
that it,
that's what comes through.
That's the thing that comes through.
Um,
yeah,
go ahead.
I was just going to say that he really took something that maybe many of us
could not relate to,
like living in a project.
And when he answered that,
when you asked that question about fear,
it made it so personal.
Yeah.
The,
I immediately was thinking to myself,
what am I fearing?
And he took this kind of out there thing and brought it deep.
Yeah.
And,
and so because it was personal then it was more important to me,
like you said earlier in the day.
Right.
And then,
and,
and I engaged with that immediately.
Right.
And he was identifying something.
I mean,
again,
that's also sort of like identifying,
putting words to a feeling that we have that is sort of undiagnosed or an on
sort of explained that is sort of a definition of profundity a little bit,
you know what I mean?
When you can actually give voice to do,
but,
you know,
put that in words,
the feeling that we share.
Um,
and that's what he did with I like,
oh,
that is our fear.
That is the fear,
right?
We're,
we're afraid that people,
that we are going to encounter somebody who is,
who we can't connect with as humans.
Yeah.
I think it's also incredible because he uses his own language.
He doesn't break out of being Mr. Rogers,
you know,
he actually manages to remain himself and still go to this really different
place for him.
And that's how I,
that's how,
at least I could tell it was really honest,
was that he was like,
you also get to know Mr. Rogers honestly in his language.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And you can see why,
like Mr. Rogers of all people would find that and especially horrifying thing,
you know,
like,
yeah.
They're like,
oh,
the people that there are bad people in the world.
It's just like such a,
it's like,
it's more poignant for was Rogers than any of us.
Yeah.
Uh,
uh,
Morgan.
Yeah.
Going off of that,
at the end he uses the word creature and instead of like another human,
it's like we're all just
like connected with another being.
It's not,
you know,
it's not within our organism.
We have a few more guys,
again,
from the chatroom Jennifer says,
of all people coming from someone who so genuinely and innocently sees the
beauty in people acknowledging that core fear is really powerful.
And Claudia says,
you can feel how carefully he's thinking about the question and that makes it
very often.
Absolutely.
I think you can hear it for the first time.
He didn't have a ready answer.
Yeah.
You know,
and that was,
that's important too.
Um,
and so,
um,
and again,
like I don't think that moment would've happened.
You know,
I often feel like there's like in every interview,
Brent,
a lot of interviews there was like this,
there's a question that's sort of hanging over the interview that if like you
can just figure out what that question is.
What's the one that's going to like sort of like what are we talking around and
can you,
can you figure out what that is and sort of present it to people.
It gets,
it breaks through often.
Like you again,
the therapy language,
you have a breakthrough a little bit,
you know,
and that's what you're sort of going for yet.
Jeff,
I'm wondering if both of those clips ended up in the final cut and whether or
not you like including that transition when,
when you get the right question and that person changing from their canned
response to,
to the more personal honesty.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
No,
cause you have to,
yeah,
no,
those are both pulled from the actual final version.
So like that's what the music was there and everything like that.
That was the,
that was,
I just downloaded the clip off of iTunes and put it in there.
That was like the,
yeah,
but,
but is that what that your answer was that
well I was wondering if you had gotten the second answer first,
if that would have satisfied you or if you'd like capturing that moment when you
kind of,
someone it's interesting.
Did you need the drama of him giving a canned answer first and then to like
break through?
There's something nice.
I mean that's,
there is something about that where you were,
it's nice too.
I like that it was the same thing that happened the day Dave Ramsey thing where
where somebody is not being totally honest and then there's a question that sort
of confronts them.
Um,
I dunno,
that's a good question.
I think,
I think it,
it helps.
I think because it also sort of tells a story.
It's like,
it's like a court,
I feel like it's like a chord resolving and music when you're just like waiting
for the court and then you finally the power cord comes and you're like,
ah,
that's how it feels a little bit.
You know,
where,
where like where like somebody is sort of like wrestling with that.
They're not being honest and being honest.
And then they,
there's a question that breaks them out of it and then they acknowledge it.
It's,
there's a,
there's a nice feeling to that as well.
But I think it could have worked either way.
Like I will have,
we often will use the,
the answer without using the question and it often is just as powerful,
you know,
you don't need to include the whole thing,
you know?
It's just how it works.
Yeah.
Well the
questions come in and I think tie in nicely to these clips that we just heard.
So I'd love to get your opinion on this.
So in that,
in that clip you were talking about getting that location,
that street in Chicago.
So this ties into a question that Braden had.
Who says when you're reporting on a town or a location or with Mr. Rogers a
neighborhood,
do you have a methodology for getting to know that town or that place?
Um,
God,
that's
tricky.
Do I have a methodology?
Uh,
no I don't.
I think,
and I think my methodology is try to find somebody who knows it better than me
is to sort of like go and find the ID,
the person who is,
I need the person who is the exemplar of whatever it is.
Like if there's somebody,
if it's,
if it's a town and there's like somebody who's in that town who sort of
represents sort of the mainstream view of the town and then identify the
outsider,
the goth kid or whatever,
who can sort of like,
you'd have a more anthropological view of the town and if you get both of those
people generally you're sort of circling around some sort of authentic picture
of it.
But you're always like,
that's the biggest difficulty of being a journalist is sort of like parachuting
in some place.
Trying to pretend,
trying to get as much as you can about the place,
but you never know.
You never know as much as you wish you knew and you never have time to figure it
all out.
You know entirely generally what I'm reporting on a topic.
When I find that I have that I'm getting the same answers from enough people,
then I feel like,
okay,
well I've done enough reporting now that I'm getting similar answers.
Yeah.
Coming up a sample from my episode with Arnold Schwarzenegger at the one and
only coming soon,
but I'm going to give you a preview but first just a short word from our
sponsors.
The Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettle bells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim.
That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review.
You are happy or you get your money back.
And I've used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim you can
also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
And now back to the show,
those days there was no money bodybuilding.
And so when we didn't have enough money,
we literally had to go to work.
It's a Franklin Niacin's Franco's talent was to be a brick layer and a very
skilled brick layer,
uh,
and learned that in Italy and in Germany,
B we're able to go and start thinking about the idea of putting an ad in the La
Times,
creating a company and calling it Europe in brick layers and masonry experts,
a marble experts,
building chimneys in fireplaces,
the European style.
And this was also a time where everything that was European was huge in America.
So we benefited from that.
You know,
Swedish massages and everything had to be kind of a foreign name or a Japanese
this and this.
So Europe into Japan and oldest places,
you know,
we'll use the names we'll use because it's for some reason that the other people
just thought that was better.
And so we use that in the ad and we put the ad in the paper.
And literally a week later we had the big earthquake,
uh,
in,
in Los Angeles.
And I mean the chimneys fell off the,
the,
the apartment houses and all stuff.
And they had cracked walls and orders.
And so frank and I,
we,
uh,
some Africa,
one of the friend of ours,
wife who was very smart and she worked in a supermarket,
um,
she did a answering the phones and calling people back and notice,
uh,
just to make sure that I in English doesn't get all screwed up with the talking
over the phone and artist.
And uh,
and,
and so she gave us in the addresses and then we got to do the estimates.
And I was kind of like set up to be the math genius and it figures out the
square footage and that Franco would play the bad guy.
And I blamed the good guy.
And so we will go to someone's house and then someone would say,
well,
look at my patio is all crack.
Can you guys put the new patio in here?
And I would say yes,
and then they will run an with a tape measure.
But there would be a dead measure with centimeters.
No one in those days could it all figured out anything that's any matters.
And we will be measuring up and say,
this is,
you know,
uh,
for uh,
meters and the 82 centimeters.
And they had no idea what you're talking about and this is so much.
And then we will be writing up formulas and the Dallas and amounts and,
and,
and square centimeters and square meters in order stuff.
And then I would go to the guy and I said,
well,
uh,
I said,
um,
it's $5,000 and the guy will be in a state of shock and you say,
it's $5,000 is it?
This is outrageous.
I said,
they didn't think that this is a well,
what did you expected the basis?
I thought maybe it's like two,
$3,000 is up at 5,000 it says,
I see them.
He said,
the talk to my guys is because he's rude.
The masonry expert.
I said,
but I can beat him down for you a little bit.
Yeah,
let me soften the meat and then so we'll go over the Franklin and was the
arguing in German,
you know,
this is any shine that I had to constantly so far field [inaudible] Arbonne here
in America and this will be going on.
It was screaming back at me in Italian and some some stuff and then that will be
always in the calm down and they,
we'll go through the guys at Fiu.
Okay,
here it is,
is it,
I could get him as low as $3,800 as you can you go with that.
And he says,
thank you very much as,
as you know,
I,
I really think that you a great man,
but I'll go blind notice epicell gay.
I said,
give us half down right now.
We go right away and get the cement and get the bricks and everything that we
need for here.
And we can start working.
I say the Monday and the guy was ecstatic.
He gave us the money.
We immediately ran to the bank,
cashed the check is to make sure that the money's in the bank account and then
we went out and got the cement,
the wheelbarrow and the older the stuff that would be needed and uh,
went to brook.
And so we worked like that for two years.
I mean very successful as a method then and we had the various different jobs
where we employed like 16 different bodybuilders.
All the laziest bastard did.
You can never hire but never the biggest.
They all were interested in working out and getting a tan at the same time for
the body building competitions.
You enjoyed this episode.
You're going to love what I have coming,
all sorts of crazy experiments,
incredible guests and you can very easily not miss any of it.
Just subscribe on iTunes or you can check out all of my guests as well as my
blog that has one to 2 million readers per
month@thefourhourworkweekdotcomallspelledoutfourhourworkweek.com.
That's where I chronicle all of my insane self experimentation and I would love
to hear from you.
So please reach out to me on Twitter,
twitter.com forward slash t Ferris,
t,
F,
e R,
r,
I s,
s or on facebook@facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two
s's,
of course.
And until next time,
thank you so much for listening.